♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE FBI'S OFFICE
HAS RECOMMENDED FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE BE
FIRED FROM THE BUREAU FOR
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT.
ACCORDING TO NEWS REPORTS,
McCABE AUTHORIZED DISCLOSING
INFORMATION TO REPORTERS AND
THEN LIED TO INVESTIGATORS ABOUT
IT WHEN THEY ASKED.
McCABE HAS ALREADY ANNOUNCED
HIS RETIREMENT WHICH IS SET TO
TAKE EFFECT ON SUNDAY.
IF HE IS FIRED BEFORE THEM, HE
COULD LOSE SOME OF THE BENEFITS
HE'S DUE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON, I WANT TO
CLEAR THE AIR ON THIS SPECIFIC
QUESTION, I'M WATCHING THAT LADY
IN THE AFTERNOONS OVER AT MSNBC
TALK ABOUT HOW THIS IS A MORAL
TO PUNISH THE SKY.
HAS HE DONE SOMETHING WORTH
PUNISHMENT?
>> HE'S DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS
WHERE PUNISHMENT, INCLUDING
CAREENING THROUGH OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, DOING
EVERYTHING HE COULD TO EXONERATE
HILLARY CLINTON IN THE EMAIL
SERVER CASE CORRECTLY.
IF HILLARY DIDN'T WIN THE
PRESIDENCY, TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO FALSELY CLAIM THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAD COMMITTED A
CRIME, EVEN THOUGH THAT'S NOT
WHAT HE'S BEING FIRED FOR, THAT
CERTAINLY ULTIMATELY WHAT SHOULD
HE BE ASSIGNED FOR.
HE SHOULD BE FIRED, HE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN FIRED A LONG TIME AGO
AND IF HE LOSES SOME OF HIS
BENEFITS, THAT'S GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S THE LEAST THAT CAN BE
DONE TO HIM.
>> Tucker: WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF HAVING A HIGH
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER LYING?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR US?
>> THE SYSTEM OF EQUAL JUSTICE
HAS BEEN --
INCLUDING SENIOR OBAMA
ADMINISTRATOR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS.
THIS IS A MOMENT IN HISTORY THAT
THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND DESERVEDLY SO.
EVERY ONE OF THESE PEOPLE SHOULD
BE PUT IN A WANTED POSTER AT A
POST OFFICE, EVEN THOUGH THEY
MAY NEVER BE ARRESTED, WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE TO THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE FBI IS UNDERMINE THE
CONFIDENCE OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IT IS DISGRACEFUL AND IT ALL
STEMS FROM THEIR ANIMUS TOWARDS
PRESIDENT TRUMP.